que tu ta béchu 9 plus tôt cette semaine
nous avons suivi le quotidien de julia
rebours une mère monoparentale qui doit
gérer un casse-tête finances il va
falloir pas maman à l'arrêt vont se
dépêche pour aller au co ses attentes
envers le gouvernement pour l'aider à
joindre les deux bouts et des grands
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez entendre de
ce budget un miracle
[Rires]
nous sommes retournés la voir
aujourd'hui pour l'informer du crédit
d'impôt remboursable de 500 $ qu'elle
pourra toucher et
500 $ unique
j'ai pas de mot ça couvre à peine ses
dépenses en essence comme représentante
d'un courtier en alimentation
qu'est-ce qui vous déçoit le plus
[Musique]
qu'ils aillent pas de
barème au niveau du pourcentage
d'augmentation
célébre au choix par exemple au niveau
des logements célébre au choix du
propriétaire
la famille font tous nous avait aussi
ouvert les portes de leurs cinq ennemis
dans les laurentides avec un revenu
familial de 92 mille dollars ils
obtiendront 1000 $ du gouvernement
hommes 5000 $ qui arrivent d'un coup
mais probablement que je veux juste le
mettre de côté puis ça va augmenter
encore plus ma mise de fonds ou si je
faire des rénovations dans la maison
qu'on veut j'espère un jour y avoir
accès leur rêve de s'acheter une maison
s'éloigne encore puisque le budget ne
contient aucune mesure pour les aider à
accéder à la propriété pour les
intervenants communautaires le nombre de
nouveaux logements abordables et sociaux
promis par québec ne suffira pas à la
demande on a la confirmation que le
gouvernement soit ne prend pas la mesure
des crises du logement vécu au québec
par les ménages locataires ou minimisent
l'urgence des besoins mais dans les deux
cas je vous dirais que c'est
catastrophique
les groupes de pression s'étonne que si
peu de leurs suggestions et été retenue
il y aurait eu d'autres mesures qui
auraient pu à être choisi par exemple
les taxes sur l'essence présentement à
vue l'alberta qui les a retiré une
meilleure façon de le faire en fait ça a
été pour le gouvernement de ne pas
remettre de l'argent mais tout
simplement d'en prendre moins en
baissant certaines taxes impôts
les avis sont partagés dans le quartier
populaire de limoilou à québec
beau 500 $ effectivement quand on refuse
de poisson avec l'inflation plus le coût
de la vie donc j'avoue que soudainement
je suis très content ben j'ai
l'impression de me faire acheter
corps humain parce que je dise 500
pièces et quads aujourd'hui c'est tout
les rangers à l'épicerie de hiran du
trop long souvent voir cogner qui va
aller jusqu'à tes orteils avec 500
dollars seulement pour elle et sa fille
julie à rebours espère encore de l'aide
pour couvrir l'augmentation des tarifs
d'hydroélectricité un gros point
d'interrogation dans son budget et celui
du gouvernement ici véronique prince
radio canada québec